[Music]  hey Dad how was your father's day  Oh another pile of gifts that made you  ask yourself do they even know me well  do built knows you which is why we've  created the DES built dad shred 3000  Father's Day gift strip it's powerful  titanium tip crosscut blades can shred  up to nine gifts per minute  you'll never fake a smile again simply  feed your gifts into the - shred let it  compress them into smoky charcoal  briquettes that are Harbhajan ready to  de built dad shred 3000 father state  gifts trader is the perfect way to turn  Father's Day fails into summertime fun  and for the dad who already has the  Father's Day gift shredder  introducing the 5000 XP Father's Day  gift regular shredder  - built for the deaths who truly deserve  the best  [Applause]  you